yo hanging out in the lobby can't wait
to see what celebrity rappers will be
joining the game
it's just football players it's time to
expose frauds based on limited info and
pure mob mentality you must vote out the
impossible bears
[Music]
the only way to prove when our frauds is
by doing silly little tasks
we have to use our legs still there oh
why is it so hard to connect
hey yo i can't get these cars to work no
problem we'd love to share targets now
rude it's trying to sabotage ain't no
front man i'm just trying to figure out
these dang masks man
france on us we won four games i guess
the nfc east
bucks are suss yeah i'm sus successful
under stress
well we're undefeated only because of
the titans situation
vote brown man every year the browns are
frogs man no no i'm trying again
the browns were somehow not frogs
several frauds remain don't eat me
it's fine i'm pretty sure it's still
fourth down
the hell yeah man violence and death now
this is a game
[Music]
never give up kids one day you too could
be an internet famous third string qb
and that's the trace mcsorley guarantee